wir leben echt in einem glücklichen land
was wir hier für probleme haben in
deutschland jetzt diskutieren wir wissen
sie ernsthaft über die abschaffung
unserer nationalhymne
haben sie das gehört was stimmt denn
nicht mit unserer hymne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die ist perfekt so wie sie ist meine
damen und herren
finger weg von der bühne
hameln
was wir für probleme außerdem haben wir
wenn wir ehrlich sind gerade doch ganz
andere sorgen seit montag ist es amtlich
das sechste große artensterben der
erdgeschichte und wir sind live dabei
freunde nummer fünf war das ende der
dinosaurier einige zdf zuschauer können
sich erinnern diesmal schaffen wir das
aber ganz ohne asteoriden einschlag und
in einem atemberaubenden tempo
wenn wir so weitermachen heißt es bald
die erde 100% tier und pflanzen frei
leider nicht übertrieben eine million
arten eine million sind unmittelbar vom
aussterben bedroht sagt der un weltrat
zur artenvielfalt und jetzt da ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass das
artensterben eine genauso große rolle
für ihn spielen muss wie der klimaschutz
ach du scheiße das war's für diesen
planeten
ich sag mal so hoffentlich nehmen wir es
ernster als den klimaschutz täglich
wirklich jeden tag sterben nach
schätzungen 130 arten aus 40 prozent der
amphibien sind bedroht genau so wie rund
ein viertel der säugetiere
was haben die fischer denn alle was ist
denn bitte das problem menschen benehmen
aus ökosystem zu viele tiere zu fisch zu
verpflanzen auch sich das einfach alles
an uns war
nein wir nehmen zu viel tiere und so
viele pflanzen gut nämlich die pflanze
wieder runterkommen
[Applaus]
leider hat der bärtige mann völlig recht
vor allem unser fleischkonsum ist ein
problem das sagen alle experten allein
die produktion von soja da können sich
einige wieder allein die produktion von
soja unter anderem für tierfutter hat
sich seit 1990 verdreifacht immer mehr
egger immer mehr monokultur dafür
weniger naturflächen kann man seinen
enkeln gar nicht mehr erklären was wir
hier anrichten
immerhin haben sie jetzt ehrlicherweise
mal das dschungelbuch umgeschrieben
da hat der kleine mogli den kompletten
dschungel gerodet um soja anzubauen und
palmöl für sein hotel abu baghira und
shir khan sind sauer sie rufen der alter
warum hast du unseren schönen dschungel
platt gemacht und das in einem so
unmöglichen ton das möglich leider alle
drei erschießen muss
ja
und noch ein ass
auch bei uns in deutschland liegt es vor
allem an der sogenannten
intensivlandwirtschaft wegen der ist die
zahl unserer fluginsekten seit 1989 um
sage und schreibe 75 prozent gesunken
und die zahl der vögel seitdem um die
hälfte
überlegen sie mal um die hälfte wie
konnte das passieren
ich gucke immer noch bürger merkt gerade
wie konnte das passieren wo wir doch
eine landwirtschaftsministerin haben mit
julia klöckner die persönlich von
morgens bis abends für die deutsche
bühne kämpft wir müssen ein gespür dafür
haben wie es der bühne geht was der
biene schadet das schadet auch uns
menschen preis der biene schadet muss
vermag tja ja genau deswegen hat frau
klöckners bundesamt für
verbraucherschutz gerade noch mal 18
pflanzenschutzmittel ohne auflagen bis
ende des jahres genehmigt was sagt man
dazu
darunter ein glyphosat unkrautvernichter
und ein insekten bekämpfungsmittel wie
war das eben wir müssen echt ein gespür
dafür haben wie es der bühne geht ja
schlecht deinetwegen übrigens bekannt
gegeben wurde diese genehmigung an
weiberfastnacht wenn es keiner mitkriegt
und die umweltministerin wahrscheinlich
als maja verkleidet
anderweitig beschäftigt war svenja
schulze von der spd für mich die beste
man müsste jetzt aber echt mal
ministerin die wir je hatten
dann muss man da was tun und wir müssen
da dringend was tun wir ja wir können
eine ganze menge tun und deswegen müssen
wir jetzt gegensteuern und jetzt müssen
wir das wirklich umsetzung wir müssen
jetzt aber auch liefern aber müssen
natürlich auch in deutschland was machen
dann müssen wir handeln nur ziele haben
das reicht noch nicht
es reicht doch umweltministerin zu
werden aber frau schulze müssen wir
sagen mein zimmer gut sie hat halt nur
leider nicht zu sagen ich sagen wenn wir
in deutschland nicht radikal was ändern
dann geht es uns bald wie den arm
chinesen die einmal im jahr per hand die
blüten der obstbäume bestäuben weil zu
wenig insekten da sind ja wie soll man
seine kinder ohne bienen aufklären frage
ich sie
pass mal auf junge wenn ein chinese und
eine blume sich ganz doll lieb war
[Applaus]
brockmann chinese macht irgendwas mit
seinem pinsel keine ahnung so in zwei
jahren gibt es die nächste un konferenz
zur artenvielfalt dann soll es schneiden
sie sich an um konkrete maßnahmen gehen
soll
dietmar wischmeyer hat trotzdem wenig
hoffnung terror nix endlich allein auf
dem planeten mit dietmar wischmeyer
gute nachrichten erst dauert nicht lange
und wir haben den planeten ganz für uns
allein eine million arten stehen kurz
vor dem ableben doch kein grund zur
panik
es sind kommen deutsche unter den opfern
die tiere müssen einsehen dass sie
verloren haben
homo sapiens einst ihre 0 weil sie weiß
es klingt vielleicht auch zu doof sind
wow dieser afa hat gelernt mit einem ast
ameisen zu jagen toll und wir haben den
thermomix erfunden und hören wir auch
mit den sekten sechs beine aber nicht
weil hauptschulabschluss peinlich sogar
tiere die mit uns zusammenleben und
eigentlich von unseren fähigkeiten
lernen könnten kriegen in wirklichkeit
gar nicht gebacken
selbst unsere dümmsten kinder sind
schlauer als der könig der savanne
da war eine scheibe du vollidiot vor
allem aber haben die tiere keine chance
gegen unsere abgrundtiefe bosheit hier
als die holländer im siebzehnten
jahrhundert die insel mauritius in
besitz nahmen lebte dort der harmlose
dodo der schmeckt nicht mal die schweine
haben sind einfach nur gequält weil er
scheiße aussieht weil er hässlich ist
wie eine rolle stacheldraht oder der
riesen alters sind knochen wir als
brennstoff genutzt haben das letzte
pärchen das ausdrücklich kein witz wurde
von menschen erwirkt das letzte antreten
kurz gesagt gegen arschlöcher wir uns
hat die natur schlägt keine chance wobei
manche regionen holen sich die tiere ja
gerade zurück ich sag nur brandenburg
das noch die frage wer sich am ende
durchsetzt der brandenburger oder der
wolf und wenn das wie beim dodo nach
attraktivität geht wer ist niedlicher
entscheiden die selbst ich halte mich da
raus
[Musik]
endlich alleine
fünfmal mehr steuerbaren damen und
herren
red
ja
das neue was war was buch über insekten
wir brauchen man kann es nicht oft genug
sagen wir brauchen eine andere
landwirtschaft weniger gülle weniger
gift und viele bauern wissen das ja auch
längst seid ja gut er wenig liebe ist
nur in können sie übrigens hat keine
toxische wirkung sie können glyphosat
ringende passiert nix maximow krise von
spruch fehler wenn überhaupt wenn
überhaupt kann er seine eine aktuelle
studie der universität bremen stellt
fest reformen in der deutschen
agrarpolitik werden zitat systematisch
von interessensvertretern verhindert und
zwar durch ein ganzes geflecht aus
politikern und verbandsfunktionären die
in brüssel und berlin
schlüsselpositionen besetzen
leute wie johannes röring obmann der cdu
im agrarausschuss des bundestages dieser
mann hat nebenbei noch 15 andere posten
in agrar unternehmen verbänden und der
kreditwirtschaft und erfährt eine
ordentliche ern verein röring gehörte in
der letzten legislaturperiode zu den
drei bundestagsabgeordneten mit den
höchsten nebeneinkünften alle drei
übrigens landwirte wir schalten wir live
in den bundestag zu albrecht humboldt
ebenfalls für die cdu im agrarausschuss
warum wollt ist die bauernlobby
möglicherweise die mächtigste von allen
er werden sonst die imker lobby
manchmal der bundestag ist unsere
hutwelker unser treff man nennt uns hier
sons of tucson stolze vertreter der
deutschen bauern also nicht der kleinen
klitschen die sterne aus aber der
agrarindustrie erkennungszeichen meiner
gang boss anzug und gummistiefel
ich sage ihnen wenn ich und meine jungs
hier über den flur gehen da die kosten
sogar die typen von der autolobby
ehrfürchtig zur seite
[Applaus]
und auch in der kantine haben vier das
sagen dinkelaker gegen den deutschen
bauernverband geht hier gar nichts ich
gebe ihnen ein beispiel 2016 die neue
gülle verordnungen da hat so ein
wissenschaftler von der uni berechnet
wie viel stickstoff pflanzen angeblich
brauchen nur 150 kilo pro hektar sagte
jacob doch kurz vor abschluss der
verhandlungen wird der wert geändert der
ausschuss empfiehlt stattdessen 200
kilogramm stickstoff pro hektar und so
darf deutlich mehr gedüngt werden der
überschuss versichert als nitrat ins
grundwasser wo er hingehört ich sag
immer wissenschaftler einladen jederzeit
du darfst nur nie auf sie hören ja das
heißt lobby vertreter in diesem
ausschuss entscheiden wie viel scheiße
ich essen muss das ist jetzt auch mal
wieder arg verkürzt dargestellt das
entscheiden auch unsere lobby vertreter
in brüssel
genau wie bei den pestiziden das nächste
modethema wo der verbraucher ständig
mitreden will
aber der wunsch des nabu zu wissen oder
überhaupt vielleicht der bevölkerung zu
wissen wie viel gift wo ausgebracht wird
ist doch verständlich oder nicht das
geht aber die bevölkerung ehrlich gesagt
zunächst einmal nichts an geht den
bürgern nichts an
der minister hat das später aufdruck
leider zurückgenommen aber dabei hat er
ja völlig recht mein eigentum ein gift
oder essen guten appetit
das problem es kann doch alles nicht
wahr sein in einigen bundesländern
brandenburg zum beispiel habt ihr
durchgesetzt über irgendwelche
verordnung das in naturschutzgebieten
gift gesprüht werden darf na klar wenn
ich bock habe stehe ich hier im
bundestag hier direkt unter der empore
sitzen die grünen da stecke ich gerne
mal einen kleinen gruß runter getreu der
alten bauernregel wenn der knecht
formsache prise denkt der habeck bucht
es nieselt
hans de schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [ __ ]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches flugweg
für ein exklusives geigensolo von oliver
welke
abonnieren sie den kanal